and a question that I really wanted to
ask you was why do you think this
particular case captured such
international attention both at the time
and then what why is it still doing it
now was it
right place right time was it the did it
have the right look look I the real
reason the initial reason that there was
huge press coverage was because the
McCanns
quite wisely they thought wanted it in
the end it became the bane of their
existence but that night when they were
sitting in their agony after the police
had come and the police had had gone for
the time being three four o'clock in the
morning they sat with their friends in
apartment five a with the little girl
missing a little what can we do that the
police how the police doing enough know
maybe they could took a long time to
come maybe they're not and maybe so we
should do something they tried to reach
out to TV stations through relatives in
the UK on the telephone and by 800 nine
o'clock in the morning the news was it
was very brief but the news was being
broadcast on Sky News and other stations
in the UK where I said that at the time
it wasn't on Portuguese news and I
gather at all and during the case it is
there's a Portuguese law which says that
information cannot be given out should
not be given out by law while it's
ongoing now that's very different from
the reality which in later on involved
you know people saying things on the Qt
saying on the quiet thing so two
journalists week we can't we're not
telling you this really but happens
everywhere it's an old-fashioned police
tactic but but it got let loose but
anyway become food from the McCanns own
effort the press first knew about it but
what the McCanns by their own admission
also thought was wait a minute this is
the edge of the Internet Gerry McCann
the father had a sister I believe called
Philomena in the north of Scotland who
was hip to computers and who had
students and she bought students or
former students into garage a sort of
makeshift shed where they said I'm
within what 24 36 hours people in New
Zealand knew about this case people who
would never otherwise have known about
it which had the effect of getting
Madeline's picture the picture that
it'll go out there to millions whereas
in a similar case in the past that it
would not have gone out to millions or
certainly not for a very long time and
in the end though starting an avalanche
of chatter on the Internet
chatter which was often far from
responsible I think you are totally
right that it became a monster of its
own and started to roll along on its own
momentum it's a difficult situation you
know the listeners at home I wonder what
they think they would have done in that
situation would you have allowed the
police to have conducted the
investigation quietly would you have
thought that that was the best route or
would you have tried to react by getting
as much information as much exposure as
possible to have this have the fault of
this little girl out there I I would
guess that the vast majority of people
would just want maximum exposure as much
it feels like you're doing something
right like you you're helpless in this
situation what can I do what can I
actually how can i impact and help you
know you're not an investigator you
don't understand forensics you don't
have these sort of things for one of the
things you can do is disseminate right
but that's that's not only your natural
reaction but it's also the best advice
from from the experts in the field you
know some of your listeners might be too
young to remember it but years ago when
you know the National Center for Missing
and Exploited Children in the u.s. first
got
for instance they were behind a great
campaign we're missing children's faces
were put on those those cardboard milk
cartons and that was a way of getting
maximum exposure because everybody got a
carton of milk yeah that was a way of
getting maximum exposure for every
missing child and it's a brilliant tool
and the Internet is a wonderful and
enormous milk carton in that sense but
so we do I mean it could it can be
credibly effective and what we do know
is that publicity does help you know
there was a recent case I believe in
Minnesota where young a young girl was
missing for a period of months and she
was spotted by a passerby because her
face was recognized you see these kind
of things in the Elizabeth Smart case
again she was recognized there was an
oddity about the the you know the scene
she was seen it by a passerby and was
brought to police attention so the idea
that maximum exposure isn't the right
thing is actually wrong it is the right
thing but it can turn around and bite
you back yeah sorry it could have been
precisely the right thing in the case of
little Madeleine McCann not least
because Madeleine McCann had a thing
called coloboma which is scientific
medical word for a blemish in her right
pupil of her right eye which if you were
if she was walking past you in in a
store or loved the pavement you wouldn't
notice immediately but it was a blemish
it was an obvious thing so in those
first days when she was missing and even
later if you had people's attention had
been drawn to this feature of her eyes
then perhaps she she could have might
have been recognized and the police or
the shop security or wherever could it
could have been called so it was a it
was like the picture on the milk carton
it was a relevant thing to do yes I
underst
[Music]
you